You only fight with people who are weaker than you. Is it not
particularly like an effective meta message that this video that
is almost entirely calling out Israeli war crimes is what Ethan
Klein is suing over. The second you picked a fight with Destiny
and got slapped, you ran away crying. You picked a fight with
these people because they're not as good at defending themselves
because you are a cowardly
But I do want to get into
the Noah Samson.
Okay, let's take a look. Ethan went live today. Title: I am suing
Noah Samson. Was he already being sued? No, he was not.
Ethan actually had never sued him because honestly, I just doubt
that there's anything that rises to defamation there. I think
one of the examples I saw was, well, he said I talked about,
you know, I tried to slander somebody for 20 minutes, but I didn't
talk about them for that long. It's like, dude, is that really
a defamation claim? Do you think that that is the claim that
led to your reputation being harmed that you talked about somebody
for, you know, 18 minutes instead of 20 minutes? Seems a little
>> Um, today we are discussing friend of the show, Noah
Samson. That's right. Spoke about It's been a while since I spoke
about dear friend Noah Samson,
>> who had a penchant for accusing me of being pro. uh
genocide.
He thought it was cute. He thought it was uh
fun throwing around such kind of heinous accusations, right?
This guy supports genocide. In fact, he had even a video called
the YouTubers that supported a genocide with me in it. He did.
And we've got some moments from that video to watch. Okay. Now,
I'm not going to do the whole video, but there are some good
sections here. Okay. >> Supremacy and >> there are
some very good sections of this video.
All right. But yes, the YouTubers who backed a genocide. And
from my to my mind, you know, going back and watching this, I
feel like we're just going to watch it be totally correct the
whole time that it's just going to be like, wow, Noah Samson
must be smarter than I thought. This guy kind of this kind of
this guy kind of knocked it out of the park. He kind of crushed
it. I'm very excited to watch that. We will once we get through
a little bit more of Ethan's intro. Okay.
>> And um you know, that's the world we're living in.
excuse me. In fact, here I just Googled his name. You can see
here I
I made a promise to him
March of last year. >> And um I think I think he probably
thought that
>> that it had blown over. >> I think a lot of people
probably thought it blew over. In fact, the statute of
>> I swear to God, you could tune a mic to not pick up
those coughs as much. Why? Like why not just have a pushto talk
button? How hard would it be to have a pushto talk button? Would
it really be that hard? It feels like there's no way it would
be that hard to have a pushto talk button so that you don't have
all the coughs going into the mic directly is passed.
I of course kept a close eye on that. You see the statute of
limitation
for certain
certain uh stat complaints like defamation and the such if you
don't sue within I think it's a year of the defamatory claim
it blows away like dust in the wind. >> Cool. So let's
take a look at when when this video was made March 11th 2025.
So I'm guessing he would have had to file the lawsuit back here
before March 11th
to what? To those of us who are shrewd, we keep we keep a tab
on those things. And I'll tell you, this is what I am assuming
is that Noah himself
thought himself to be shrewd.
I even alluded to it on this show. I
well, it seems to me that Noah is ducking
out playing hookie on society. >> Dude, the way this guy
talks is
He's he like you could he's like doing an anime villain monologue
in his head. Like the thing he would be saying in his head on
his stream
now for those of us who are a bit more
We Dude, shut up. Literally just talk.
I Who thinks this is cool? This guy is such a loser, man.
>> He seems to be on the lamb. He's got no name on utilities
or anywhere that for example if you were to to hire a private
to get the information on somebody to serve them. He he couldn't
be found. >> Yeah, definitely just to serve them
>> which I'm assuming at that age in your life has to be
an conscious attempt. And so we we waited,
you know, and on the day of or the day, >> dude. Noah Samson
is so savvy living with his parents at 30. Doesn't have his name
on a utility bill or anything. I have no idea how we're going
to find this guy. It's crazy. HOW ARE WE GOING TO FIND HIM? He
He lives with his parents. That's like a cloaking device. >> Before
the statute
uh expired, >> I don't know if he lives with his parents.
I assume so. H we had a nice little complaint there for defamation
for accusing me of being pro- genocide in favor of genocide.
Horrible thing to say about someone by the way. One of the worst
I would say maybe even of all the things you could say about
someone,
you know. Well, we filed it
beating the statute by about one day.
Now, most of the time people see these
immediately, but we were under the radar. We filed it in um
Orange County, I believe.
>> Why, dude?
All of the things he said so far, it's taken 4 minutes to get
here. This could have been said in 30 seconds.
It was difficult to find this guy. It seems like he was kind
of hiding out. All right, we hired a private investigator. They
couldn't find him. So, anyway, we did eventually find him. And
now we have filed the lawsuit and shockingly he hasn't said anything
yet. Boom. Done. All of the stuff, all of it, it's all there.
Now, you could take a little bit longer, but we've stretched
this out to four minutes at this point. What are we
Which um is not trolled by uh media and press. So, it went under
the radar. Nobody even saw until now. In fact, nobody's knew,
Oh, no.
Ethan.
Ethan thought people cared enough about him that like they were
following his every move that they would find this lawsuit and
complain about it. Ethan was probably waiting days with this
lawsuit filed, just waiting until somebody dropped the bomb for
him. Just waiting. They're going to find it soon and then I'm
going to And then eventually after like a week or two weeks,
he's like, "Fine, I'LL JUST MAKE THE STREAM MYSELF. I'LL JUST
ANNOUNCE IT MYSELF. I'LL JUST DO IT MYSELF."
That's what happened here, right? That's clearly what happened.
He just he was waiting. He was anticipating. Everybody freaking
Oh my god. He filed a lawsuit.
And just every everybody's like, "No, we don't really care. No,
we're not looking into anything on you." Okay.
You could sue him in the background. Yeah. E Ethan literally
just said, "Well, I thought people would be trolling for this
stuff, but I guess the the press doesn't troll the, you know,
this civil court or whatever." And well, you know, he clearly
wanted somebody else to to see this. He wanted somebody else
to bring it up. that uh we I was even suing Noah Samson. Well,
he knew since a couple of days ago, since he was served,
>> but he's the only one.
Turns out Noah, thinking he was clever,
came off the grid.
It was time to come out of hiding. So, I thought he was doing
because it turns out right after
we filed this uh lawsuit of ours
that we did another very standard boilerplate search
like private investigators do every day to >> dude. So
after you filed the lawsuit, you did another search for him.
the recipient of such complaints to serve them
as you have to serve them as a very integral part of
suing somebody
>> and I've been involved in a lot of lawsuits and I've
never had this types of trouble locating someone for service.
But you know, just like when the rain falls and the worms and
snails come slithering out of their shelters
>> for one drop of rain,
>> so too came slithering Noah Samson. >> Is this
like is he just describing like Noah
moved out of a roommate arrangement into his own place and signed
a lease and then he popped up on some things because he probably
registered utilities
like not thinking about Ethan Klein at all. He just lived with
like a roommate into his like later 20s and wasn't thinking about
it and then moved out and then popped up.
Ethan's Ethan's making this seem like Noah Samson was hiding
under floorboards from Ethan Klein, but he wasn't. He's definitely
just living his life. I don't think, dude, it was such an absurd
lawsuit to file in the first place. Surely Noah Samson was just
living his life, just like talking just living his life normally.
And Ethan has concocted this whole fiction in his head about
how it went. Very goofy, man. Turns out it wasn't rain, it was
the sprinklers because we caught him
and we served him. And Noah Samson, who was served about two
days ago, has been pretty mums of the word on it.
has been sued now in California for defamation. That's right.
He thought I forgot. And the hilarious thing about this is like
at this point you're suing a guy on calling you a genocide supporter
because you're a Zionist. You're suing him for that. Does Ethan
not understand that Noah's not even going to have to pay his
own legal fees? Does Ethan not understand that this is like a
massive wedge issue and lawyers all over the country would love
to see a latigious Zionist get his like pushed in in court? So
there's no way he is going to get like he's not going to pay
any legal fees. There are going to be lawyers jumping up and
down to cover this to to represent him and like that's just obviously
true. No,
like what what are you hoping to accomplish here?
What are you hoping to accomplish at all? I I don't get it.
Oh no. J was so much better content before he capitulated to
Hassan and his mob every stream. He's crying about the lawsuits,
but he knows deep down Ethan is going to win. Hated Ethan Klein's
lawsuits before. I can't remember when he filed them. hated them
for the second they
I don't know what the you're talking about, man. And this one's
even more of a slap lawsuit than the others. Like, this one's
even more frivolous than the others. This one's embarrassing,
frankly. Okay,
this one is straight up like just a total attack on free speech.
It's 100% just an opinion. There's no shot, no shot that Ethan
wins this. He's hoping that he could just like basically take
some money from Ethan's. Uh, sorry. He's hoping that he could
take some money from Noah Samson by making him pay legal fees.
That's what he's hoping for. But I don't even think he's going
to get that. By the way, I never once said that any of the people
involved in the other lawsuits were going to win their
So, I hope it tells you something that I could say, "Oh, they're
going to lose even though I disagree with the lawsuits." But
this one, I'm like, "Oh, Noah's got it in the bag." Easy.
Easy.
In fact, nobody should be surprised. This is me following through
on a promise I made uh a year ago. And by the
oh, but I will say, notice how he wanted Noah Samson. Dude, he
loves this weird power game every time.
Noah Samson got it two days ago, and he's been very quiet. I
thought he was going to say something, but I guess I'll say so.
>> many people uh friends and comrades of
>> have said that I'm only suing women.
And it's been, you know, me, of course, I have a majority female
audience who I respect women
>> more than anyone in the world. I love respect.
You only fight with people who are weaker than you. The second
you picked a fight with Destiny and got slapped, you ran away
crying
immediately.
You picked a fight with these people because they're not as good
at defending themselves. because you are a cowardly loser.
That's the difference. Okay? It's not that you hate women. It's
that you just like fighting against weaker people to make yourself
feel powerful. That's all. It's very standard stuff. Everybody's
met some bully, some loser like this in their life. Okay? You're
not special. You're pretty regular
women. And so
>> to dispel this terrible
accusation that I only sue men or women, I'm sorry, I thought
it only fair
and equitable to sue a man, >> a white man, I might say.
Um, >> very brave.
Well, it's it's equitable and and I want and it's important for
me to know to the three women
that um
it's not personal, right? I I it totally is personal.
It absolutely is personal. Why even lie about this? Why lie and
show up and say, "Oh, it's not personal." You're just obviously
lying.
I We've already gone through this all the cope about his other
lawsuits. It's just personal. He just wants to go after people
he dislikes personally. That's why when he extracts his apology,
he extracts apologies for
for some reason.
Oh, you know, Casey Trron, AS A PART OF MY legal settlement,
you need to apologize to Asmin Gold. What a
He's trying to network. He's trying to network off these lawsuits.
What an embarrassing loser. Sue those who who deserve it, who
who who require accountability. And it was a terrible coincidence,
a terrible one,
that the three people I sued for copyright infringement were
women.
Terrible, right?
And I'm just happy that I've had the opportunity to rectify that,
to set the record straight now, to sue a straight white man.
And I think nobody should be more relieved for that, to have
that set straight, other than Noah Samson himself,
who was a woke, legendary king. And now he can rest easy at night
that Ethan Klein doesn't hate women. He just hates losers who
do dumb and bad things. Gender, race, be damned. I come before
you a man, a simple man. And that's basically what I want. Know
what it takes also
today.
But when his head hits that pillow at night,
he can know that he lives in a just world where women are not
bullied into silence. It's not about that. Gender equality is
at the is at the the the
core of everything I do and know as well. So take solace, my
friends, all of you. Equality reigns
in America in 2026. At least in this house,
>> in this house, women, men of all races and ethnicities
are being sued. That's what it means to be American. And I
for the horrible optics that suing three >> I had to mute
there for a second. I had to mute there for a second to get the
toos violations out. Guys, I've gotten them out now.
Okay, I'm ready. I'm locked back in. I had to mute there for
a second to just like say all of the things that I needed to
say. And now those are all gone. We've we've got that catharsis
and we can go back to covering it just calmly. All right. Very
calmly. Thank you. >> I tried to convince everybody. I
said it's not about their gender.
It's about their statements on THE >> I WILL LOVE A WOMAN.
>> Their intentions to steal from me. But that wasn't enough.
>> Okay. I super don't care about any of this stuff at
all. I'm pretty interested in seeing exactly what this video
says and trying to see like, do we really think this is defamatory?
Are these really the statements that Ethan wants brought back
up? Does he want to be the person attacking somebody for having
these feelings? I think that would be actually really I think
that would be really good for us is to go through and just watch
a little bit of this video and see what's the vibe, how's the
what's the feel like. Okay.
>> I Yeah. And then we'll get to Ethan actually reading
a little bit of the lawsuit. I think so. requires a certain level
of dehumanization to keep its inhabitants from collapsing under
the weight of the reality of their rotten society. Another way
to get a handle on the seemingly ubiquitous genocidal fervor
among Israelis is by just talking to them. >> How many
civilians have been killed in Gaza from what you know?
>> We're g
this is the honest to god truth. I really hate to say it. Okay.
Zionism can't survive contact with the average Israeli voter.
It literally can't. If you're an American Zionist, your Zionism
cannot survive contact. Okay? That is the number one thing that
will turn somebody into an anti-ionist is just contact or or
understanding of the average Israeli voter and what they think.
That will that will obliterate you. Okay? It'll crush you. If
you're an American, you believe in American ideals and you go
there, you will never say the line, "Well, they kind of believe
in our principles and stuff. They're like a liberal democracy."
Nope. >> Nope. Nope. >> Okay. But don't you feel
like for example children
>> children grow up to be Arabs. >> What the heck?
>> My memory died and went to heaven. I don't think children
should suffer but they're always casualties
and since they do a lot of pure vu
that is a natural result.
No spinach.
>> I've never met like a a group of people that so often
like invoke the fifth amendment when they don't live in America.
I declare an answer pertinent to my fifth amendment rights.
Because I It's better we stop asking or talking. Why is that?
Because I don't think anyone there is innocent. Wow.
most of the kids there that are getting killed. I'm never I I
never support little children dying, you know. I never want to.
>> Let's
I knew there had to be one. I knew there had to be there had
to be one. >> But But most of
No, NO. NO, NO, NO. Don't say but what? No, no.
>> Grow up not only supporting Hamas, which is a crime
by itself, but joining them, which is the worst of the worst.
The sad the saddest thing of all is I do believe that these people
basically got like a very quick hit of what the Palestinians
experienced like over years over decades right and the Israelis
like caught up basically like a lot of Israelis caught up immediately.
Now, there were a bunch of Israelis who were already there and
doing a bunch of crimes to the Palestinians, doing a bunch of
war crimes and stuff, but the average Israeli citizen after October
7th, anybody who was like remotely pro peace, like those people,
those people dried up very, very quickly. And the unfortunate
thing is you have a bunch of American Zionists who remember what
people were like before October 7th and they will talk about
their opinions before October 7th in Israel and how they felt
about things. And it's like, dude, that's a different world.
That's an entirely different planet than the one you've ever
been to or had any contact with. Okay.
>> There is no Palestinians. They're Arabs
who have many countries to flee to and nobody wants them to.
But if we do call them Palestinians, their parents use them as
uh human shields to gain sympathy. The natural instinct of a
mother is to protect her child. Palestinian Palestinian women
do not have that >> these people know that they're on camera
and that these remarks will >> these are this is particularly
psychotic right like you have to have an idea of how this that's
why it's funny cuz some of them just go yeah I'm not I'm not
going to talk to you I can't talk to you okay I can't talk to
you at all it is very concerning >> do not have that >> these
people know that they're on camera and that these remarks will
be posted on now uh I will say as a little caveat
They're probably going to take, you know, if the AS project is
about, you know, exposing
genocidal ideology in Israelis, they're probably going to only
talk to specific people, only publish specific interviews. I
polling is more helpful, but polling really doesn't help you
here. Polling is pretty rough. Okay, public polling is also very
much in line with these opinions. Like, these people aren't the
99th percentile extremists. These people are like they're within
the first standard deviation of the mean, okay?
like like they're within the first standard deviation. Don't
think that they're 99th percentile. They might be a little bit
and there would be some people on the other side, but they're
not they're not even extreme. These people aren't advocating
like, hey, we have to go further. We have to get all of them.
We have to take out everybody.
That's a significant portion of on the internet or shared on
the mainstream news. This is normal to them. This is normal in
their society, which is a testament to the fact that their society
is not normal. It's typically bad for him to site street interviews
as being some meaningful indicator of widespread attitudes, but
>> let's go. He's going to handle that. Oh my god, I don't
think I watched this video before. Did I? >> Again, with
Israel, it's just different. Not just because these attitudes
align perfectly with the wider Israeli polling data, but also
because it's almost impossible to find anyone in Israel saying
anything else. The amount of truly anti-ionist Israelis living
in Israel numbers in the hundreds. This figure is according to
anti-ionist Israelis themselves. They are alone. >> Everyone
around us are completely
genocidiled maniacs. Everyone around you. And I don't mean it
metaphorically. It's not metaphorically. It's literally everybody.
It will be your family. It will be your teachers. It will be
your colleagues,
everyone around you. So you'll alone. Even if we will gather
all of the all of those anti-z together from Jerusalem or Tel
Aviv or Kyifa or whatever, it will not be more than I don't know
500. >> There's no tangible internal opposition within
the country. The Israeli left is a myth. This is reflected once
more in the openly genocidal sentiment we see on social media
from IDF terrorists who have been >> Oh, holy [__]
Hold on. Wait.
Oh, this is like uh are they playing footage from HOW DID HOW
DID NOAH Samson get in a time machine and get footage from Lebanon
yesterday or two days ago and put it back in this video? How
did he how did he get where did he get a time machine?
Oh, you're telling me that they've done that before? Oh, well
that seems >> Tangible internal opposition within the country.
The Israeli left is a myth. This is reflected
>> that that's more like C4 demolition, right? That's more
timed C4 demolitions happening behind people as they tear down
entire apartment blocks, an entire way of life as they obliterate
it, they remove it from the earth.
Very cool. >> Once more in the openly genocidal sentiment
we see on social media from >> Nice. Yes, it definitely
the one thing I could say about this place once more in the openly
genocidal sentiment we see on >> what I what I would say
about this place is there's too many buildings standing. It looks
like people could possibly still live here and ek out some sort
of existence. We need to change that immediately. Let me call
Let me call the Let me call the boys. Let me call the boys. We'll
get a hookah and we'll go fix it. It looks like some people could,
you know, ek out some bleak,
dreary existence in this area. And we don't want that. We don't
want any existence at all. >> On social media from IDF
terrorists,
>> Much better. We blew up all of the buildings. Much better.
posting their own war crimes on the internet for everyone to
see for a year and a half. >> They go into the homes of
Palestinians and they're often clearly staying there and they
just smash them up and they film themselves smashing them up.
They also delight in going through women's underwear drawers
and this is a >> wow what
this seems really particularly disgusting. No >> sort of
recurring obsession. You have to see his >> wow that seems
particularly disgusting.
You know what I'd say about that? If I were a totally
if I were a totally if I was a total zero empathy psychopath,
I might say something like, "Maybe don't put that on film." Hey,
maybe maybe the only criticism I have there is that you filmed
it. Don't film it, man. Hey, you know, if I was a psycho, if
I was a total psycho, I might say something like that. Maybe
>> Israeli soldier videos in the context of the broader
output of Israeli society. If you gave me a button to just erase
Gaza, every single living being in Gaza would no longer be living
tomorrow. I would press it in a second.
I would press it right now. Give me that button and press it
right now. >> There you go.
>> The look for this guy. The look from this guy, dude,
bro. This guy is sitting here like, "Are you are you okay, man?
Are you good? Are
what the question was? What did you have for breakfast today?
Hey, what did you what did you have for breakfast today? >> Broader
output of Israeli society. >> If you gave me a button to
just erase
>> what what are you doing tomorrow? What are you doing
for like uh what are you doing for the holiday coming up? If
you gave me a buttons,
>> every living being in Gaza would no longer be living
tomorrow. I would press it in a second. I would press it right
now. Give me that button and press it right now. >> There
you go.
>> And I think most Israelis would. >> There's an
Israeli song called This Was My Home. And what they would do
is dress up as caricatures of obviously what they perceive Palestinians
to be sung mockingly to people who no longer have homes. We're
not looking at some sort of obscure
subculture within Isra. It's like honestly the comparisons to
Nazis
at some point start to become like I don't know if were the Nazis
like dancing and joking about gas chambers. I don't think so.
I think a lot of the broad populace was like ignorant to this
happening. Like I like at what point do you go and I'm I'm going
to be careful with this one, but at what point do you
are the comparisons to Nazis offensive to the Nazis?
Like at least in terms of the general
sure the crimes are worse. The crimes are slightly more directed,
but like at least in terms of the the citizenry, when you say
like Israel's like Nazi Germany supporting the Holocaust, it's
like no, they're actually far more in tune with what's going
on. They actually know far more about the inner workings of these
war crimes and exactly what's
It's disturbing. It's like, I'm not even saying this as a thing
to laugh about. It is frankly disturbing seeing things like this,
seeing young kids like this and then they will come to you. So
people will come to you when they argue on behalf of Israel and
go they're taught Palestinians, Gazins are taught to hate Israelis
from the time they can like hold a gun from the time they're
four or five. And it's like, oh yeah, must be monstrous people
doing that to them, right? Must be monstrous people teaching
them that. Yeah, must be total >> Believe Palestinians
to be being sung mockingly to people who no longer have homes.
We're not looking at some sort of obscure
subculture within Israeli society. This is mainstream Israeli
>> People have been keeping tabs on this. There are a number
of archives documenting the names and crimes of these Israeli
terrorists. One of the most thorough of these databases was created
by a historian Lee Morai. It's called Bearing Witness to the
Israel Gaza War. It is presently over 120 pages long with extremely
detailed footnotes. There's that one tweet that's like, you know,
hitting translate from Hebrew on Twitter is
Dude, the [__] translate button. >> Discovering
a lost page from mine comp. This holds up pretty well here. Let's
try it on this tweet. Uh, the survivors of the 2025 Holocaust
are proof that every trace of the murderous mutations in Gaza
must be erased from delivery rooms to the last elderly person
in Gaza. 100% dead in Gaza. That there is Barashi Kinet, the
host of a mainstream Israeli news channel. One more.
Bro, what the
I don't think I watched this video before.
I don't think I watch I hope I didn't watch this video before
cuz if I was like thinking, you know, if I was sort of ideologically
dug in and defending Israel and I watched this video, I can't
imagine the monstrous things I would say. Holy, man. Like, I
think we're b we're basically convinced. The only thing I'm seeing
here is is essentially that he's correct. Let's start watching
where he starts talking about Ethan Klein. Atrocity propaganda
has consequences. So, with that context out of the way about
the Gaza genocide and its support from the West and within Israel,
the broader media system that allowed it to happen, let's now
return to Ethan's video. In the content nuke, you can find just
about every type of what we just looked at in terms of manufacturing
consent. Ethan, okay, so the argument is going to be that while
Ethan doesn't want people killed, he's not going to say he wants
people killed. He's going to manufacture consent. That means
he is essentially going to do some form of propaganda, not necessarily
even characterizing it as evil, but some form of propaganda that's
going to make you see the Palestinians as less deserving of protection
or more deserving of retribution. So, he will continuously cover
these stories, continuously focus on these stories, right? And
I'm I'm assuming Noah would have some sort of explanation or
examples of like here's here's the Palestinian side of the story
which he has laid out in the previous like 40 minutes and now
I'm going to show you how Ethan Klein covered it and how what
the disperate, you know, numbers are. So like as this is getting
worse and worse in the Palestinian side, you expect people to
start talking about it more. I'm guessing that doesn't
We'll watch. >> Red's atrocity propaganda. He shares the
Hamas mass hoax. the same hoax that was used by the Western media,
the US government, and the Israeli government to justify a genocide.
He cites the same sources that these parties site when they go
on stage to legitimize more military killing machinery shipments
to >> And October 7, last year, Hamas committed horrific
acts of violence.
Cheryl, I thank you for all your work to bring to light the horrors
of this issue and for your film about what happened on October
7. >> In his video, Ethan spreads overt misinformation,
just straight up lies about Hezbollah and Ansar Allah or the
Houthis in order to delegitimize their struggle against Israel's
genocide. He cites baseless claims from Saudi state propaganda
outlets to attack the Houthis. He also cites a documentary about
Ansaralo which he uses as proof of the claim that they brought
back slavery when the documentary wasn't even about the Houthies.
It was about the Yemeni government before the Houthi takeover.
He spreads long oh no debunked Nagba deniialist talking points.
Talking points that have been used for decades to legitimize
Israeli colonization of Palestine. He incites sources that contradict
his own claims directly such as the UN report he claims proves
the
>> what did what Kamala said wasn't wrong. No, I wasn't
listening to the Kamala quote. I was doing something on the side
here. I have no idea if what she said was wrong. Wasn't listening.
>> Mass allegation. >> There's a UN report that concludes
it >> which the report itself denies. He spends 20 minutes
in the video smearing a 19-year-old survivor of the USbacked
Saudi genocide in Yemen as a terrorist with zero. >> So
again, that's going to be over mass rape,
right? Like mass rape as in like something coordinated. That's
what Noah is referring to there. >> Credible evidence.
He makes a number of transparently false anti-semitism accusations
like his claim that Israel's ban on new account signups from
Israel was anti-semitic. >> Around the end of the year
when people started talking about anti-semitism on Twitch, Dan
Saltman discovered the Israel ban when he was sent the code proving
the block happened. >> In reality, the ban also affected
millions of non-Jews living in Israel and Palestinians in >> Dude,
um I knew some people around this time. I used some people who
worked at Amazon and they're like, "Dude, they know they have
such insane
like like uh oversight. They know exactly who's looking at what
line of code when the person who leaked this to Dan 100% got
fired and 100% is like black balled in that industry. That person
had to have got maybe not. Maybe they go, "Oh, well, it was over
some issue like this." And maybe they on political grounds didn't
want to get any smoke over it. But like, if they just follow
procedure, the people at Amazon were like telling, "Oh my goodness,
it was it was so over for this guy, whoever did this." Like,
this this is insane. An insane thing to do given the level of
scrutiny they're under. Palestine, as shown in the evidence he
himself cites, the IP ban went into effect in both. Like all
these Western liberal outlets, Ethan just takes the State Department
line of thinking when it comes to terrorism, which his video
is ostensibly a crusade against. By his own definition of terrorism,
both the US and Israel are the largest terrorist organizations
in the world. Given their history of killing millions of innocent
civilians across the globe, his focus is not on them though,
rather the groups that they consider to be terrorists, aka, you
know, the bad guys. He actually uses those exact words. He says
it's they're the bad guys. >> They are a designated terrorist
group by the US, by the EU. These guys are clearly the bad guys.
>> The entire video is kind of a lie by omission simply
because of everything we just went over. How none of it is a
factor. How none of the people viewing the video that are unfamiliar
with what's happening would ever come away with his video knowing
the full picture. Knowing some of the very valid reasons why
someone like Hassan might be critical of Israeli atrocity propaganda
or might support groups like the Houthies for their heroic actions
in the Red Sea against a genocidal regime. The biggest issue
I think is that
>> again I I totally get because I literally have to hold
myself back like emotionally from getting to this line. I totally
get how you say like I don't I literally stand tentoes down with
the Houthies. Any opposition to Israel is good. The things they're
doing are horrific. I get it. Just not kidnapping you know disconnected
civilians. That's that's where I draw the line. Obviously >> that
Ethan >> didn't Han introduce him as a member of the Houthies
though.
Yeah. But why would that matter to Ethan making a claim that
this guy's a Houthy? Why? Why would that
>> I don't know why that would matter. >> Do all
of this while still calling himself a stalwart ally to the >> And
I've been >> it was him being physicious. I do not think
it was Hassan being physicious. I think Hassan definitely thought
this guy was a part of the Houthies, but >> A stalwart
supporter of the Palestinian cause for many years. >> This
is what makes liberal Zionism so insidious. He is using humanistic
appeals to things like peace and safety, but doing so in a way
that distracts from the actual source of the problem. The problem
is Zionism and the genocidal Israeli state. That is what's causing
these problems. And people that might otherwise be able to understand
if presented with the facts of the situation are simply led astray
by people like Ethan, where a more right-wing Zionist might put
off the average liberal with extremist claims and overtly genocidal
language. A liberal Zionist draws you in with the facade of empathy.
He wants to appear >> I didn't even notice that Ethan's
like pretending to play Marvel Rivals in the
Well, I didn't know what Marvel I didn't know Marvel Rivals when
I before. Oh, no. He's got a stream on. Who's Who is he watching
play Marvel Rivals? He's watching somebody stream Marvel Rivals.
Who's this >> language? A liberal Zionist. >> Never
mind. He's not pretending to play. He is watching a stream with
it on. >> Draws you in with the facade of empathy.
Marvel empathetic as if he cares for these people. as if he doesn't
ascribe to a genocidal ideology. So, in order to do that, he
has to lie and roping in otherwise progressive people into a
death cult. Aside from this video being a nonsensical genocidal
propaganda piece, it's also entirely unoriginal. The video is
a culmination of a monthslong campaign against Hassan and all
these other creators and Twitch the company to smear them as
terrorists and anti-semmites and get people, you know, in trouble.
The campaign began as a response to the suspension of the live
streamer Asmin Gold. Asmin Gold made some comments that explicitly
justified Israel's genocide of Palestinians in >> I'm not
going to cry a river when people who have genocide that's baked
into their laws are getting genocided. They come from an inferior
culture. I don't feel bad for them. I don't feel sorry for them.
I don't He was showing Hassan playing Marvel to make the point
that he was doing that during a genocide as opposed to watching
the content. Duke,
pay attention to me, Hassan. Hassan, pay attention to me. pay
attention to me. >> Inferior culture. I don't feel bad
for them. I don't feel sorry for them. I don't care. I don't
support them. >> Following his suspension for these comments,
a community of large content creators, most notably the live
streamer Destiny, along with his fan base, rush to Asmin Gold's
defense, whitewashing and justifying his comments. >> Meanwhile,
Asmin Gold gets a 15-day ban for having a spicy take on the war.
>> You have someone like Asmin Gold who breathes the wrong
direction. >> Dude, I think I think I got this. I think
I nailed this at the time with the Asmold thing. I I'm pretty
sure I said like I don't think he has genocidal intent, which
I guess you could say is wrong now. Like he seems to basically
love he kind of does the coveting death thing. But before that,
I did feel like Asenold was just and we was speaking poorly.
Like I I had no problem with Twitch banning him. I had no problem
with people thinking that was a genocidal comment. It was, but
then he took it back and I'm like, "Okay, he took it back." He's
like, "Oh, I shouldn't have said it. I didn't mean that. I didn't
want to say that. And who knew that he was just lying? >> You
have someone like Asmin Gold who breathes the wrong direction,
says the wrong thing and instantly gets banned. >> In this
situation, one could, you know, if they were to extend the charitability,
could say that Aspen Gold was probably referring to extremists
in the Islamic religion. Extre.
>> Yeah, this is totally false. in the Islamic religion.
>> The case of Asmin Gold suspension from Twitch was then
weaponized against these >> he's he's pretty aggressively
arguing for like I think he doesn't understand that Persians
are kind of like somewhat white. I think he doesn't understand
that then like the racist hierarchy. Asold is like a performative
racist. He has hatred but he has no none of the knowledge of
like most online racists. He's got like the hatred which is an
essential element but he just hates in like totally random directions
with no understanding of why he does. Okay. So he probably thinks
Iranians because they are Muslims
that they are or the Iranian regime is Muslim that they are like
all Arabs. They're not right. If Persians are white then Mexicans
are white. You're just trying to get white status Vin and you
can't get it. I'm sorry.
I'm sorry Vain. Uh,
but like in terms of how people think about like ethnic hierarchies,
like actual racists, they don't think Persians are like that
low. And it's funny because if he if he knew that, if he had
any understanding of that,
he says that after he figured it out, okay, I somebody sent him
something on this elder baby goose. He didn't know this before.
I I know that he says that now, but he didn't know it before
when he started running like defense for all this.
Anyway, I'm just I'm saying like I feel like that would change
his opinion on the whole genocidal comment. Like the whole uh
wipe a civilization off the map. Or maybe not. I don't know.
I don't know, dude. I What is that guy's ideology at this point?
Whatever Trump says, I'm I'm down with all the time. He like
that he says Trump's Trump fell off and then he just still sucks
Trump's all the time without saying the name. Like everybody
now, all of the total Trump sickants, they don't say Trump's
name. They just argue the same points without saying his name
cuz they know it's bad optics. It's very goofy. Uh prop Palestine
voices, most notably Hassan, in an effort to get him deplatformed.
To do this, they compiled a number of short clips taken from
Hassan's live streams using them to accuse Hassan of things like
supporting and promoting terrorism, allegedly denying October
7th violence and making anti-semitic statements. Each one of
the clips and their associated accusations can be traced back
to prominent posts on Destiny's subreddit. Uh some of the clips
were sourced from videos that criticized Assan from well over
a year ago. These clips were initially hosted on a website created
by a member of the campaign called
Soon after another >> it's a old man website created danclansancy
sucks.com a reference to uh the CEO of Twitch Dan Clansancy.
Another goal of this campaign was to get him fired from the company.
This site also hosts all of these clips with their associated
allegations anti-semitism.
>> So here's the thing. Some of these clips I would agree
some of the clips of Hassan I would agree venture towards anti-semitism
in some cases. The the what did Hamas do think that's I thought
that was a little over the line at the time. I even think like
now it's a little over the line. But
the thing I'm always going to do at this point is I'm going to
look at these statements statements like this and I'm going to
basically say okay if you're like towing over the line and not
like sprinting over the line. You tow over the line you pull
back you like kind of realize it was a little too far. Then I'm
like, okay, I I don't have a lot of heat because it's just an
emotional topic. Like I understand how it's difficult to disambiguate
the state of Israel from his population. So sometimes when people
are like speaking freely, things can get conflated. They look
kind of like anti-semitism. But realistically, if you're speaking
out with like horror at the things Israel is doing, I have a
little bit of a buffer zone there for you at this point where
I'm like, I'm not going to I'm not going to declare you anti-semitic.
And I understand that might feel unfair to some people,
but that's the way it is now. Um, and I just wish that buffer
zone gets bigger and bigger as they do additional war crimes.
Okay,
it's
it just keeps getting bigger. Like the appropriate response
is screaming. The that's the appropriate response, right?
I think that was the analogy I did at the time. Actually, the
appropriate response to what Israel is doing in G in Gaza RIGHT
NOW IS,
you know, that's the appropriate response. That's what you should
be doing. If you're not doing something close to that, I don't
know what you're talking about. I don't know what you're doing
here. Terrorist promotion and denial. Eventually, several major
YouTubers in the usually a-olitical commentary sphere made videos
that signal boosted these allegations to millions of viewers.
Most of these videos used the same clips, many of them directly
citing this smear campaign's website. There's a website known
as danclansancy sucks.com.
>> Oh, hold on. Okay, he is going to go through this and
the entire argument here is going to be if you're going to consistently
minimize the actions of Israel, never talk about them, attack
only one side of the argument, right?
Like it will come time to take into account like everything everybody
said.
if you can still look at the beginning of October 7th and the
course the war took and the propaganda that came out, what's
been disproven, what we know now, if you think Hassan [__]
was contributing to the problems here, if you think he had any
contribution to the overall net the negative effects in the world,
you are a [__] Right?
And
how do I put it?
I think probably the people who were more educated on how Israel
had acted with regards to the Palestinians in the past for the
most part
were immune to that kind of propaganda. They saw the atrocity
propaganda coming out. They called it out. They said, "Do not
trust this." And a bunch of people went, "Oh, so you like don't
so you deny rape. You like don't believe women. You just totally
deny rape. You just deny rape." Cool. Okay, cool. Hassan [__]
hates women, denies rape.
And then you get to see that like all of the things that he was
saying or a ton of the things that he was saying ended up being
if not if not like true I won't say facts he could have gotten
facts wrong right but the general like idea he had the general
attitude he had towards the conflict was the correct attitude
to have if we didn't have that attitude if if people had that
attitude broadly the attitude that Hassan or Noah Samson had
at the start of the conflict the people the you I think you still
have conunists I Communist still exists today.
That's the problem. There are literally neo-Nazis physically
accosting people in dozens of American states right now. And
while I think Hassan has been a careless, I think that that the
lack of concern over those neo-Nazis and fixation over Assan
is troubling. Sure, that's also a problem in America. I'm saying
that it's like Hassan could be doing something wrong. He could
be rushing to judgment and all of these things, but the argument
really was that he was rushing to judgment and he was wrong at
his core about what was going on. It if it was just tone policing,
then the tone policing was the tone policing was immoral. You
know what I'm saying? Like the tone policing was totally out
of place. It was the wrong approach. And I think that's ultimately
what a lot of the anger towards Assan was was tone policing.
It was it was once again the Vos clip of we need to prioritize
the feelings of people over everything else. The feelings of
Jewish people matter more than anything else. Multiple Palestinian
lives, tens of thousands of Palestinians lives. No, the feelings
of people far more important to all of us. And and I say people
because I say like American Zionists or whoever like people who
are more concerned about possibly anti-semitism rising than speaking
up about the war. And now it's come to the place where actually
all of the crimes from the war are coming out. People are seeing
them and saying, "Oh, wait. Why did you accuse people of being
anti-semitic? This is genuinely horrific. This is genuinely monstrous.
What? Why did you say anti-semitism when people were saying these
things?" And it's like, "Well, they were being really imprecise
with their language."
Uh, what?
Wait, that's that's all that happened. They're being imprecise
with their language. So you basically tried to minimize the alarm
the these people's uh you tried to minimize the alarm people
felt at what was going on because they were a little imprecise.
You understand that makes you to me it makes you look a little
bit complicit, right? I'm not going to go well Hassan was he
said that a hospital was bombed cuz he didn't trust Israel.
Okay. How many hospitals got bombed? Oh, all hospitals in Gaza
have been damaged, have been hit to some extent at at bare minimum.
Every single one. Oh, well,
well, that looks that makes you kind of look stupid now, doesn't
it? That like he was right on all of them except one, maybe.
Does that make you look dumb? I feel like it does. >> Or
there's also a website that's been created called Dan
goes over it all. Another website, Advertise on Twitch, shows
a collection of ads playing before the dishonestly framed clips
we've looked at, and the contact information of the companies
is provided. It autoloads one click, allowing participants in
the campaign to mass spam these companies with the related smears.
There were several motivations behind this campaign. Um, you
know, there were direct material incentives on YouTube for the
past few years. There's a a big industry that's exploded in popularity,
and it's based on a simple concept, Hassan. Bad. Assan [__]
is bad and he's dumb and bad and a terrorist. Probably we can
call this the Hassanabi dunk.
N. Yes. Yes.
It
is bad. We're We blow up everywhere. We're so
We're blowing up everywhere. Okay. >> Video industrial
complex. It's common for YouTubers during low view months to
join in on the fun and make these types of videos. Taking short
clips from Hassan's thousands of hours of live streaming to misrepresent
what he's saying. usually pariting the exact same talking points
they're getting from the same YouTubers in the same community.
They're watching each other's videos and making each other's
videos. It's kind of like a perpetual cycle of dumb guy slop.
It's interesting to see YouTubers that typically cover Tik Tok
drama and gaming content randomly giving their opinions on genocide
and geopolitics, but that's the result of such an ecosystem.
It's not about the politics. It's about making money by attacking
a guy they don't like because the guy in question happens to
be a political content creator. they have to try to do politics.
It's really funny to watch. Honestly, it's also wild because
the political content creator in question is an anti-genocide
content creator and the arguments they're attacking him for are
anti-genocide arguments. So, these creators, you know, they're
positioning themselves uh in opposition to him and his arguments
de facto positioning themselves on the pro- genocide side. You
know, anti- anti-genocide is progenocide. It's quite the >> Oh,
this was after I was like doing Hassan's bad already. This was
this was funny. There's so many people um there's so many people
who just didn't understand which way this tweet went that like
a bunch of DJers retweeted it and I was like literally mocking
I was literally mocking them. That's the funny part with this
one. This is like me mocking them for all of this with this.
People didn't get it which was helpful >> precarious predicament
they've
>> wait that absolut that's March Wait that was May 2025.
I absolutely was on that. That's my position in May of 2025.
We're already doing bad at that point.
May
>> Whoops. Whoops. Back to this. >> Not back to this.
Back to this. >> In. Do they realize it? No. Do they care?
Probably not. But that's what's happening. That's >> uh
No more linking my tweets in this chat. No more of this. Shut
up. >> That's what they're doing. The success of this video,
which garnered over 3 million views in its first month, is a
testament to the algorithmic viability of Hassan bad content,
get in front of a politically illiterate American audience and
call a pro Palestine influencer a terrorist promoting hateful
terrorist music videos. >> Terrorist propaganda videos,
>> terrorist propaganda video, >> collect big fat
AdSense check. That's how it goes. And Ethan knew it would do
well, too, and made sure to get a sponsor for the video. Thank
you to ExpressVPN for sponsoring this video, >> which was
a VPN company that happens to be owned by an Israeli billionaire
with a history of funding and supporting the IDF. He's not a
Zionist, though, apparently. Apparently, he's not a Zionist.
And he's prop Palestine. >> I've been a stalwart supporter.
>> Which one? Hold on. Hold on. Which one was it? Aman.
Who was it? It was Teddy Sagi. I don't know who that is. Wow.
Never heard of that guy. Cool. >> A history of funding
and supporting the IDF. He's not a Zionist though, apparently.
Apparently he's not a Zionist and he's pro Palestine. >> And
I've been a stalwart supporter of the Palestinian cause for many
years. >> A few years ago, Destiny was banned from Twitch.
Since then, he has repeatedly attempted to be reinstated on the
platform and the latest attempt by using the campaign was probably
the closest he's ever been in terms of putting pressure on the
platform. >> We're tired of your site changing the rules
every week. No, >> I still haven't seen anything that I
feel like is wrong about Ethan Klein.
I've seen Ethan I've seen some stuff. I've not seen a single
thing that I would define as like incorrect about Ethan Klein.
This looks like rock solid to me. >> Nobody knows what's
going on. Get your [__] together. Unban Destiny and
make a site that people actually want to go to. >> Dedicated
the last like two weeks of my life basically to Steve's cause.
>> Hey Twitch thing. >> Yeah. Destroying Twitch.
>> Some of the motivations for the campaign are political
in nature though. Obviously, you know, Hassan Biker is one of
the most prominent pro Palestine voices on YouTube. And this
campaign has been orchestrated by Zionists. The website that
started this campaign, hamaspiker.com,
doubled as a donation page for a prominent Zionist organization.
Since learning about the existence of Israel on October 7th of
2023, Destiny has positioned himself as its number one cheerleader,
showing up to debates to defend the genocidal apartheid state
using Zionist talking points and denying that a genocide is taking
place. On the Lex Freriedman Israel Palestine debate, Destiny
justified Israel's slaughter of four Palestinian children in
the Gaza beach bombings using talking points plucked directly
from IDF spokespeople. >> Those kids weren't just on the
beach as often stated in articles. Those kids were literally
coming out of a previously identified Hamas compound that they
had operated from. They
with all due respect, you're such a fantastic [__]
It's terrifying. I left Finkelstein's iconic response in there
because he >> dude, you're such a fantastic [__]
Uh, actually though, like realistically,
there's absolutely no reason to believe Israel when they go,
"Oh, well, we previously identified that is a that is a Hamas
compound."
There's just no reason to believe them. He is 100% correct. The
events of that day were witnessed by dozens of journalists. There
is no real dispute as to what happened except from of course
the party that slaughtered the children which is Israel and in
turn its propagandists like Destiny. He's also explicitly called
for the genocide of Palestinians. >> Honestly, uh I'm pro
genocide. Like it it sounds really but like I think that Israel
should just draw it borders about where it is now and basically
Palestinians can go live in another place. That's that's really
but like that's about where I'm at. It's this guy and his community
who are the source for every one of the arguments that Ethan
makes in his stalwart advocates for Palestinians normally. >> That's
that's not a serious comment, right? Like that's not a serious
research comment. That was before he looked into it at all, but
I mean it's something he said if you want to work off of that.
I I just wouldn't take it seriously to make a point. But he's
using other evidence to make his point about the community, right?
>> Collaborate with advocates for Palestinian genocide?
No. No, they do not. In my opinion, Destiny's podcast co-host
Dan Saltman, uh, the other main driver behind this campaign and
the one spearheading the creation of these smear websites, is
also a Zionist. Saltman promoted pro-Israel organizations like
the ADL and stopped anti-semitism and Zionist politicians like
Richie Torres, who shared and boosted the campaign. He consistently
weaponizes Zionist talking points, like asserting that any reference
to Zionism is actually just coded anti-semitic language. The
implication there being of course that criticizing Israel and
Zionism is
>> The best was when Dan said I actually don't want Do
you remember when Dan said I actually didn't want them to like
prevent them people from using Zionist like this? He said that
after after they made the rule. He was like I never wanted them
to do that >> language. The implication there being of
course that criticizing Israel and Zionism is inherently anti-Semitic.
That's a very common Zionist tactic. It's like the Zionist tactic
in the West at least. Perhaps the most significant >> si
your engagement don't don't criticize other people for their
engagement with the video when you critically engaged in the
worst possible way in a totally moronic way. You don't get to
DON'T GO AT OTHER PEOPLE IN THE chat right now. Hang your head
in shame for 5 minutes and then come back and talk normally though
and indicative of the sort of unserious nature of this campaign
is just spite. These people all seem to have deep personal vendettas
against Hassan and these other creators. That should give one
pause when considering the seriousness of the campaign that they're
running. God, he's so cringe. >> Wow. It's almost like
we could double this up for the existing campaign right now considering
it's using all the same materials again. >> He's like such
a cringe loser. I would pay so we raise a million dollars to
send this dude to go fight in Yemen and then all of us would
volunteer for the Navy. Holy [__] He's such a cringe.
Destiny has for almost 5 years just obsessively talked about
Hassan on his channel. He's made video after video about him.
Uh the frequency of these videos increased after Destiny was
banned from Twitch. In the span of time since then, he has uploaded
almost 80 videos about Hassan out of a total of like 450 videos.
So that's at least 1/5ifth of his working life spent >> And
what's wrong with that? What's wrong with being a little obsessed
really >> about Hassan? In contrast, in the same span of
time, Hassan has uploaded over 1,200 videos, and he's talked
about Destiny a total of five times. Five. Four of them have
come in the last few months while covering Destiny's role in
this smear campaign and the credible allegations of crimes against
him. So, that's less than 1% of his coverage. This isn't an internet
beef. Hassan has a stalker. With Ethan, I feel like I can kind
of spot the moment that he started going into this direction,
which was the moment that people started calling him racist for
saying racist stuff. There was one argument he made where he
compared uh voice anti-ionist activists to capos. >> There
there was collaborators with
>> Please don't say that
are akin to capos. Like that's >> I'm telling you that
the mere existence of voices doesn't is not it's not a leg to
stand on. I don't understand that. >> The chat started
calling him a Zionist freak because that's a Zionist freak thing
to say. And then since then he's sort of constructed an entire
mind prison around the idea that he's not racist and anyone calling
him racist is actually the real racists. Because Hassan's community
is politically oriented and is able to spot the racist rhetoric
in question, that means they're all extremists and Hassan is
leading them. So he's an extremist and that Hassan and them are
all the problem that he's a perfect angel, which is the direction
he's taken. It seems like >> my only crime is wanting a
two-state solution instead of one and thinking it's not okay
to kill Israeli civilians. That's it. That's why they're calling
me a Nazi Zionist. >> And now he's just totally gone off
the rails. He spends most of his time cower. >> But like
that was the original criticism was
basically people were probably a little bit too aggressive to
Ethan Klein. That was the original criticism.
That stops being the case once he makes it like his his life
mission to destroy the people criticizing him. Okay. After a
little while, that's not really the case anymore.
>> And fear behind Instagram stories
respond to. Every single one of the uploads on his personal YouTube
channel in the last number of months have been targeted towards
Hassan. He spent most of his live podcast talking about Hassan
and calling him a terrorist and whatnot. What is this, bro? I
have not I think I I have not seen a single one of his [__]
Instagram stories. I didn't know he was posting about me this
much. Oh my god. every day. >> Noah Samson made it seem
like I was obsessed with Hassan when statistically uh like only
4% of my time was spent talking about Hassan. So statistically
you couldn't say I was obsessed.
I feel like that's what we're going to see. But
we apparently do have the whole lawsuit now. Let's go. We got
the whole thing. The whole thing. Let's go. No. Now you just
have to listen to me cough once every like 60 seconds instead
of listening to Ethan cough once every 3 seconds. Let's
>> The genocide of Palestinians.
The defendant's defamatory video was incredibly successful to
date. >> Oh, wrong wrong wrong video. Wrong video. Back
to this >> day. You're no. >> There was that one
Instagram story where Ethan Klein was uh having to evacuate due
to the wildfires or something and he managed to make the post
about Hassan and about how Hassan probably thinks it's awesome
that his house might burn down while his, you know, family is
in the background trying to evacuate the wildfires. Just wild.
Ethan Klein has repeatedly denied any association with uh this
campaign and Destiny or his community. That may have something
to do with the recent credible allegations that Destiny is a
criminal, but this is false. Ethan has been caught on his live
podcast browsing the Destiny subreddit for arguments to use to
attack Hassan leaked Discord log. I'm pretty confident that Ethan
was getting talking points from Dan, like people around Destiny
to say it was like Destiny. It's It's not. They're not talking
directly, but like I know that Dan and Ethan were talking. I
know that people were sending stuff. It could have been like
through intermediaries entirely. It could have been Desty fans
who were fans of Ethan. I think I saw what it was,
right, that was getting passed over. And I I think I know like
what happened there kind of, but
I I just it like it's basically no-name people in the communities
that I think I know are, but it's like there's no reason to name
them or really talk about it cuz it's just like they're they're
just people who are fans of the content. No reason to put them
in the crosshairs of anyone. showed Dan Saltman admitting to
exchanging emails with Ethan and the H3 team personally during
the campaign. And even if there wasn't evidence of direct communication,
you know, the far more important connection is that Ethan is
saying the exact same things using the same out of context clips
that everyone else used to call Hassan a terrorist.
>> No, you don't understand. Implying truth are coordinating
behind the scenes is anti-semitism.
But you're saying the SAME THINGS. IT'S ANTI-SEMITISM
>> or whatever. It's been a group effort. That's just what
it is. So, just a few final thoughts here. Um, Zionism is Nazism.
It's an ethnic supremacist expansionist colonial ideology. You
can't have Zionism without genocide and ethnic cleansing. That's
the end goal of the project. It's what it is. Palestinians are
I mean, that's probably I don't know if that's necessarily true
like in terms of like the labor Zionists who originally went
there. It was definitely bastardized into something where in
the modern day that is all true. I don't disagree with in the
modern day I would say there's some aspect of like of labor Zionism
where I'm like nah that's not true about labor
>> are there and for the Zionist project to be complete
jar them out bomb them destroy everything they need to live those
are the methods those are what they're employing as we speak
and like Nazism Zionism cannot be defeated through reform or
debate it must be destroyed from the outside through efforts
made by the Palestinian people >> I totally disagree with
this uh you're going to require people on the inside unfortunately
I mean, cuz this is this is like a Japan situation
that that is probably the better comparable is the Japan situation.
I think I think it's far better. Yeah. I don't know how to I
don't know how else to put it.
And unfortunately, it took a lot to stop Japan. I'm obviously
not advocating for that with Israel. Obviously, every possible
thing should be exhausted before going to any sort of military
engagement.
But I'm saying that the ideological fervor with which the Japanese
were doing like their war crimes with which they were fighting
back against everybody. I think that's very similar between the
two populations. I'll give someone follow just right now. I'm
saying like the new follows seem to all be people trying to get
around. So if it's just some random name and just nuke them.
That is my position. Hold on. That's literally my position. Stay
is cut off all contact cut off all aid to Israel until they've
actually taken steps to fix things. Yeah, that's the whole that's
the actual
I feel this way. I do feel like like it is ideological like they
will dig in and keep trying to get rid of the Palestinians and
keep trying to prosecute all the campaigns they've got going
on. I think they'll try to do that. I don't know how they manage
it without the aid of the United States. So, Palestinian resistance
and coalitions of allies. As history has shown, the downfall
of these kinds of racist ideologies is possible. But Zionists
cannot be a part of this process. They're Zionists. They uphold
Zionism by spreading Zionist propaganda and spending all their
time and effort attacking anti-ionists even as those anti-ionists
are actively fighting against a genocide uh that Zionism is the
ideological pretext for. In the case of liberal Zionists like
Ethan Klene using his weird personal Zionist crash out as a jumping
off point to educate people about the ideology that he adheres
to is a great use of time I think and Bad Empanada has done a
fantastic job with that. his videos have reached pretty wide
audiences and exposed them to uh the reality and history of the
genocidal Zionist project. That's a really good thing. That's
a really important thing that he's doing. And I think many of
you can probably also help out with that. Most of you have smartphones
and cameras and Tik Tok.
That's what that's what I say, guys. Who's the best at this?
Bad
So go ahead, start posting about it. spread the
I will say
for bad empanada
I've heard that basically his main channel where he does like
political stuff is good. I honestly might feel like possibly
mirroring the probably the argument for not mirroring like the
old Hassad opinion which is you know for his video essays maybe
it's fine especially on Israel but a lot of his personal stuff
his personal engagements which he is uh very much like Destiny
doxing people being a total den wishing like death on people
very similar people in that way okay
I trust me I understand that he could easily go after me for
that comment but they're a little bit similar a unlucky >> aside
from being a morally good thing to do, it's also becoming sustainable.
You know, it's algorithmically viable. The Ethan Klein crash
out industrial complex is booming. Uh, and we can harness it
as a propaganda machine to expose Zionism for the genocidal ideology
that it is. You may have the feeling, as I often have, that the
history books will look back upon these times and those who supported
the Gaza genocide with shame and horror. Um, the only problem
with that is that these people feel no shame. They're here to
make money and to convince themselves that they aren't evil.
And the way they do that is by lying, by spreading liberal Zionist
propaganda. It's profitable and it's easy and it's acceptable.
You're allowed to say that. >> It's funny how people different
people come onto the ladder of this whole idea at different stages
in time. And I'm sure everybody thinks I'm sure Noah has thought
this at different points like how did I ever think something
different if he ever did, right? And I come in and I'm like,
"Dude, how do you not like change your mind on Israel at this
point in time, right?"
Now, why did you pull that chat up? Because it was funny.
It was funny. It was very funny. I think, but to me, I I like
sit here. I'm in total disbelief. Like how do people at this
point with the stuff happening in Lebanon, literally Israel putting
this ceasefire that's supposed to help put to rights in any small
way, it's not going to help almost at all, but in any small way
put to rights the global economy and Israel is like nah you most
bombs on Lebanon in a day that we've ever done. Boom boom
Like oh so like you're totally sabotaging this immediately, right?
Okay, cool. At this point I don't understand how the US response
could be anything but you're on your own.
You're on your own. Bye. You're on your own. Oh, also those F35s
you bought, boop, those are off. Those don't work anymore. Have
fun. Bye. Bye.
That you think all Palestinians should >> I'm pro genocide.
And still get invited to Jubilee as the resident liberal. You're
allowed to do it and and run your quirky, epic, silly podcast
and make hundreds of thousands of dollars doing that because
the Western media ecosystem encourages it. There will be no justice
for the Palestinian people if all we do is watch content about
what's happening. Consumption is not politics. There will be
no justice for the victims of this genocide unless we all actively
fight for it from the position. No, it barely even talked about
H3. It was not a lot of the content about H3. I'm guessing there
is stuff woven in and we didn't watch the whole video. I'm guessing
that Yeah, there's like going to be some stuff. I think I just
saw Ethan there, right? No, I didn't. That's the people wearing
the underwear. Oh god.
I'm guessing it's woven in a little bit >> that most of
the viewers of this video have. That's by using the resources
and time to continue to speak out, preserve the record of what's
actually happened in Gaza, name the perpetrators and highlight
and boost the voices. I will say, is it not particularly like
an effective meta message that this video that is almost entirely
calling out Israeli war crimes
is what Ethan Klein is suing over? Is it not crazy that he went,
"You know what? This video is so offensive to me, deeply in my
core. I'm going to sue you for defamation over this video.
More in-depth clips. Maybe the lawsuit will have more in-depth
clips. Maybe, maybe, maybe." I do I do notice I think is this
not the video where he also throws in the bit about how actually
what can you do about this? You can attack supply chains. You
can fire bomb a data center.
I was a little too far at that point in time. Like I think it's
just basically always a little too far that will end up hurting.
But I think that was this video, right, where he says that. I
feel like bad for cutting this off, but it's literally not relevant
to what I'm doing. Definitive. Nicholas Doro take on the lawsuit.
Nicholas Dioro. Now, this is going to be a tough one. How do
we want to predict this? We We do want to predict. Hold on. We
do want to predict.
>> I predict a lot of fence sitting. You you would almost
never expect that a fence could bear this man, but it can because
he's up on it, right? I feel like it's going to be Well, I don't
know if Ethan should do this. I don't know if I would do this
if I were Ethan, but you know, uh he's allowed to do this. This
is his right as an American. So, you know, I [__]
Noah Samson and and I think he's a piece of so I don't really
care if he gets sued. That's that's absolutely what it's going
to be. All right. I think so. I think that's what it's going
to be. You know, probably what the the criticism here should
be is, well, you know, the level of lying that's going to be
put in this lawsuit, I would be guilty of. So, I actually think
I actually think that probably isn't the bar for suing somebody
for defamation. I would really hate if this were the bar for
suing somebody for defamation cuz then I'd be getting sued a
lot. So, realistically, you know, using my empathy, my unique
human skill of empathy, I should be totally against this. Also,
I've been totally against this in the past. >> By the way,
segregation is not real. There's 20% of the population in Israel
is Palestinian full citizens integrated in all levels of work
and life there.
One states is not going to happen and I don't think it's a realistic
uh idea either. Sorry. I think it's kind of silly to even pretend
like that's not just a genocide of the there solution.
Do does like I don't understand when people say one state. Do
you guys think they mean like tomorrow every wall comes down,
one state, one person, one vote, you redo elections, and you
reset all of the laws if if Arabs win the elections? Do you really
think that's like what they mean? Do you really think that's
you don't think there's going to be some kind of constitution
that is is that is set up with the idea that it's two populations
like mixing together and over time,
right? Like obviously there's some concept of slowly working
these populations back together but not having one live in total
like totally oppressive circumstances. Yeah. Like like literally
you could have in I know in the colonies in the in the British
colonies you would have people who were like representatives
of Britain who had effect like some power in the government,
right? You could do the same thing here. Some like third party.
The United States could sit there and be like, "Oh, well we're
going to adjudicate these things." Now, you might not get a lot
of, you know, that might not make you feel a lot better for the
Palestinians, but it's better than nothing. Maybe
has it been so far, but maybe. Okay, without further ado, let's
listen to the Nick take.
>> My position on the Noah Samson lawsuit was I think this
guy just defames people constantly. You can go find out in Rob's
Media's video about what a snaky piece of this guy is. So, the
fact that he's getting like shell shocked right now that a lawsuit
is coming,
did he defame Ethan Klein? That's a classic. That's a CLASSIC
DEFLECTION.
WELL, he actually defames other people a lot. Like Chud Logic.
He might have defamed Chud Logic. I think he actually took it
back when Chudlo Logic pointed it out. Did he not? I thought
he was like, "Oh, I didn't realize this was but maybe not." In
any case, he probably is very cavalier with what he says, especially
when he doesn't have a good idea of what the facts are. There.
He'll say rumors without being without being concerned about
it at all.
Right. I do agree with that. But did he defame Ethan Klein is
the question. Not has he ever defamed somebody. Could you argue
he's defamed somebody? Did he defame Ethan Klein coming his way
and he's potentially fleeing the country or something? I thought
it was really funny. I don't necessarily think it's it was worth
suing him and I'll wait to hear what the justification was today,
but I was kind of happy that he was just living scared for an
entire calendar year. That was
>> Yeah, because you can take your name off of all the
records once they're there. He was definitely living scared and
not just like, hey, like a a drifter of some kind living with
his parents or like a roommate or something cuz that's what it
is, right? He was probably on his parents cell phone plan or
something and then he lived with a roommate maybe. He just didn't
have bills so they couldn't find him through his bills. That's
what they're saying, right? He said he was wrong but justified
it. Got it. Okay. So, he just didn't have bills. That's what
Ethan said during the thing. I there's no indication he was living
scared in any way. >> Living scared for an entire calendar
year. That was particularly funny to me. Uh because he deserves
it. He's like a little piece of he deserves to be looking over
his shoulder because >> wait the H3 community doxed him
twice. >> Honestly, he was running a little um
he's malicious. That's the issue. That's the issue about it.
He's malicious. And he showcased that he's malicious multiple
times already. >> To Ethan. To Ethan. To Ethan. He was
malicious to Ethan. Where was he malicious? To Ethan.
Where are you pushing back against any of the arguments? What?
What? Do you Do you hear that? Do you hear how obvious that is
that he's trying to avoid actually rendering any judgment on
the lawsuit itself? He's going, "Well, in a bunch of other cases,
Noah Samson really sucks." So, you know, I haven't really thought
about it, but uh in a lot of other cases, no Samson really sucks.
And I'm just happy that he was running scared for a whole year
and and and and it so Noah sucks and he had it coming. Okay.
But did Ethan have grounds to sue him? Was is what's your opinion
on that?
Total
classic cowardly fence sitter
Wild. I don't know if there was enough to swim there necessarily,
but um
good one, man.